moi personnellement le maquillage des
femmes et je trouve que c'est très joli
bon en ce qui me concerne moi j'en ai
rien à [__] parce que je suis
célibataire donc vous comprenez ça me
sert pas grand chose
le maquillage des femmes qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez je trouve que c'est
parfait et vous ça dépend de quel point
de vue on le voit alors allez-y c'est le
seul jeu de se maquille un peu c'est
pour donner ma chaîne un petit peu trop
âgé pour se cacher alors je trouve que
c'est pas joli parce que quand on les
voit le matin en fait moi confiance
moi j'appelle ça de la peinture parce
que vous croyez qu'il est indispensable
qu'une femme se maquille en principe oui
enfin tout dépend il y a un maquillage
et maquillage
le pot de colle et puis le maquillage
discret
à mon avis elle est beaucoup plus jolie
quand elle est maquillée légèrement tout
au moins sans trop de sensations ou
certainement parce que vous savez au
lever il y a pas beaucoup de femmes qui
puisse vanter d'être belle au départ je
pense pas moi personnellement le
maquillage des femmes écoute je trouve
que c'est très joli en ce qui me
concerne moi j'en ai rien à [__] parce
que je suis célibataire alors vous
comprenez ça me sert pas grand chose il
y a le maquillage qui est fait d'une
façon correcte et par des professionnels
et puis le maquillage le maquillage fait
par les intéressés eux-mêmes et qui est
quelquefois un peu un peu outrancier
disons je crois que certaines personnes
devraient prendre des cours de
maquillage
vous êtes chauffeur routier en général
dans les camions du chauffeurs routier
il y a des photos de pin-up qui sont
plutôt maquillées ce que vous aimez les
femmes maquiller
c'est embarrassant comme question mais
toute façon j'aime ma femme les
maquillages actuels c'est-à-dire c'est
visage de porcelet un peu si vous en
pensez
une fille se maquille avec le bleu là
qui met sur les yeux le phare et puis
les gros joues roses là je suis contre
les Baumettes roses non une femme
se maquille beaucoup
non elle se fait pas les yeux elle se
maquille les lèvres et puis un peu de
fond de teint quoi de voilà c'est tout
du vert un petit peu sur les paupières
enfin mais très léger parce que au début
j'ai vu qu'elle en mettait un petit peu
trop alors je l'ai conseillé en mettre
un peu moins qu'il part et si elles
avaient envie de se maquiller qu'est-ce
que vous diriez bah je crois que je
crierai un petit peu ah bon vous me
voulez absolument pas qu'elle se
maquille
est plus belle au naturel
combien de temps une femme met-elle pour
se maquiller d'après vous oh je sais pas
la mienne mais 5 minutes dans la glace à
tout casser vous voyez un coup de peigne
un peu de rouge à lèvres puis ça va me
mettre en trois quarts d'heure une heure
une demi-heure trois quart d'heure je
suppose entre un quart d'heure une
demi-heure un quart d'heure disons alors
là je suis pas toute la journée à la
maison devant la glace à l'usine 8h
devant la glace 5 minutes comme tout le
monde pour s'habiller puis [__] le
camp le soir elle se démaquille ah le
soir se démaquillage allez démaquillant
et elle se démaquille le soir je crois
que oui
pour dormir non ça s'en va tout seul
laissez-vous des femmes qui n'ont jamais
utilisé le maquillage ah oui j'en
connais enfin moi je suis votre homme en
Bretagne je connais des femmes qui ont
jamais pris un bras de maquillage c'est
sûr je crois que ça existe mais c'est
rare il y en a pas beaucoup mais il y en
a c'est les biens sans maquillage je
suis tout à fait pour est-ce que vous
l'imaginez non maquiller
j'ai déjà vu
[Musique]
sur la figure sur les yeux sur le
ridicule pédicure le coiffeur tout ça ça
faites-moi confiance
en maquillage parce que je sais que ça
ne coûte pas très cher
[Musique]